[Music]
don't move let me see it don't move amy
i see it okay ready
i love it that's super sweet because
it's terrible
[Music]
[Music]
the day the monster uprising
was the day i lost everyone only a small
fraction of humanity survived to move
than around
i've been scanning for amy the entire
time
and now i finally found her oh hey joe
amy is that you oh my god
hey a pro is amy's colony
85 miles it's an impossible journey
everything will try to kill you
don't fight just run and hide okay
you really got me going you got me
you all alone me too you don't have to
talk about it
you wanna come with me
yeah yes it is listen to your instincts
out here man
what if i have terrible instincts
you'll die super encouraging speech
you made it all this way for a girl huh
do you ever hear the term fools
no amy i miss you we have lost this wall
we could still take our world back
you're more of a survivor than i thought
oh that was awesome oh i feel like tom
cruise
[Music]
you